every town has its urban legends an
unnatural abomination with the body of
an animal and the head of a human
lurking the forests a bridge said to
curse any who stand under it in the dead
of night a lurking serial killer
continuing his crimes from beyond the
grave you might be familiar with the
hook man a chilling tale about a young
couple finding a man's hooked hand
hanging on the back of their car or
tales about mysterious clowns being
sighted in the woods outside of suburban
areas over time the truth behind an
urban legend will become muddled and the
original story might change countless
times before emerging in its present
form they might entertain us they
sometimes might even scare us but all
urban legends feed on the tiny sliver
that they might be true that voice
inside your head telling you that it
might not be just a story designed to
scare you and that there are some
aspects of the world that are truly
unknown and most of all you the average
person can get caught up in this world
forced into it against your will by pure
chance a deranged killer an unknown sea
creature lurking in a lake a curse a
poorly understood creature never before
seen by science all of these images
conjure up fear but when combined with
the personalized nature of an urban
legend which adds familiar places names
and situations to the mix it's no wonder
why these stories take off rodney
hallow's town the name of which has been
scrubbed from all documentation by the
foundation was no different in that it
had its own share of urban legends even
though the town's name is lost due to
the scp foundation wiping its name from
official documentation know that rodney
was an average teenager living an
average life and doing average things a
person his age might do
and that included taking his friends up
on dares that he might regret later
dares pertaining to those urban legends
kids daring one another to do something
like this is nothing new whether it's
saying bloody mary three times in a row
before a bathroom mirror in the dark or
taking a trip to an abandoned building
and staying the night there you should
be undoubtedly familiar with how these
things work and how easy it is to get a
susceptible young mind to do them who
wants to risk an encounter with a
supernatural while people who don't mind
to do them well people who don't want to
chicken out in front of their friends of
course getting cursed by a ghost or the
more realistic possibility of
accidentally injuring yourself while
exploring an abandoned area is nothing
compared to the feeling of satisfaction
that comes from looking cool in front of
your friends at least that rings true
when you're 14 years old but rodney
hollow was above that he was more than
anything else a scaredy-cat to his core
no amount of peer pressure could make
him fold because his fears outweighed
his social capital if rodney was afraid
of it his friends knew that there was no
chance of getting him near it in a way
it was admirable he could be offered
money food literally anything he wanted
and if rodney didn't want to do it he
wouldn't not just that but he felt like
he physically couldn't it was like every
bone in his body would freeze up his
heart would start beating intensely and
he would internally panic it was a
regular feeling of fear sure but rodney
felt it often a fear of exams a fear of
the future snakes spiders open windows
at night rodney was always overthinking
things and his spheres were well known
among the small circle he associated
himself with naturally rodney's friends
acted their age and spent a lot of time
trying to come up with new and exciting
ways to scare the daylights out of the
poor kid this could be playing pranks on
him giving rodney phone calls from
hidden numbers or trying to get him to
watch horror movies it was getting to
the point where rodney was more annoyed
than anything else and he was beginning
to heavily reconsider with who he hung
out with but if there was one person who
could convince rodney to do something it
was claire a girl in his class he had a
tiny bit of a crush on and by a tiny bit
we mean that rodney was so willing to
make himself look good in front of
claire that he willingly accompanied his
friends to a supposedly haunted house
located in a rural area just outside of
town
this was rodney's town's urban legend
and while it wasn't well known this
broken down house was slowly gaining a
reputation among the town's youth as a
gateway between the realm of the living
and the dead the lore vary depending on
who you asked but it was said to be
haunted by the spirit of a puppet maker
who experimented with making puppets out
of human bodies his reclusive nature and
isolated lifestyle meant that his crimes
and experiments went unnoticed until his
death when law enforcement seized the
house and cleared out hundreds of
mutilated half-human half-wooden puppet
creatures of course this was all just
hearsay and there was no actual proof
beyond what was said at rodney's lunch
table but as seasoned viewers of this
channel know in the world of the scp
foundation there is always a kernel of
truth and even the slightest story of
the unknown the outline of rodney's dare
was simple he and clara would have to
spend an hour inside the house alone
while his friends waited for him outside
of it pretty great friends huh under any
other circumstances rodney would have
refused to even leave his house that
night but the prospects of looking good
in front of claire were too tempting for
even the scariest of scaredy cats to
pass up besides if he played it cool he
could use this as a way to talk to
claire and actually get to know her a
bit better they'd have a whole hour
together just an hour inside a dark
dilapidated house occupied by a puppet
maker serial killer's ghost that's all
still rodney clenched his fist and grit
his teeth determined to shake off his
reputation as a wimp the house stood
before him and claire stood beside him
they moved forward together much to the
chuckling and stifled laughter of the
kids behind them and with a forceful
jiggling of the locked doorknob using a
makeshift lockpick made out of a
paperclip and a piece of metal they
entered the house the inside was dark
but that much was to be expected as soon
as the two entered the door slammed
itself shut and a clicking sound was
heard indicating that it was now locked
immediately rodney knew something was
wrong he had a feeling he would see some
unexplained things but he didn't expect
one to occur immediately after he
entered the door just slammed itself
shut claire turned back and attempted to
open it but she had no luck rodney and
what he felt was a smooth move told her
to calm down and that when the hour was
eventually up they could just break
through a window to get out this seemed
to work and claire hesitantly calmed
herself the interior of the house was
old done in a baroque style unfitting of
the unimpressive exterior a spiraling
staircase a few paintings armchairs in
front of a fireplace it was clear that
whoever lived here if they didn't have
money they certainly had access to
skilled craftsmanship there were faint
pockets of light in the distance coming
from candles positioned sparsely
throughout the home the two began to
explore not content to stay in any one
place for too long the frightened duo
came to an ornate yet run-down kitchen
their footsteps creaked with every
movement but when they stopped they
noticed that the stepping sounds didn't
rodney began to panic as he was used to
keeping a cool head in this situation
was next to impossible slow-stepping
sounds coming from various parts of the
house they moved closer practically
clinging to each other if rodney wasn't
so scared this would have been an ideal
situation but he couldn't even
appreciate it the footsteps didn't grow
louder they just increased in number
slow moving steps coming from above
below and beside them and then in the
distance from the poorly lit hallway in
front of them rodney saw a shape a
jerkly moving barely visible shape but
it was approaching them claire saw it
too and the two ran out of the kitchen
and back to the front of the house they
banged on the door begging and screaming
for their friends to let them back out
but there was no response they tried to
break open a window but they physically
found themselves unable to damage the
house it was as if they wanted to
protect it instead of damage it even
though both of them knew they absolutely
wanted to break a window and run out of
the house as fast as possible the figure
was approaching and the footsteps didn't
stop either it was then that rodney
caught a glimpse of the figure that was
trailing them a picture only visible due
to the brief flash of candlelight it was
a sunken hollowed-out corpse with button
eyes and rust brown skin as soon as it
moved beyond the candle the entity was
difficult to see again but rodney was
unable to scrub that brief image from
his mind it jerked towards them slow
step by slow step and then it lunged
forward at a frightening fast unnatural
speed the two screamed rodney fell to
the floor passed out in fear and then
everything went quiet rodney and claire
were just another disappearance that had
a connection to that abandoned house and
when the local police force launched an
investigation they compiled over 20
cases of teenagers from ages 12 to 17
that went missing as a result of
visiting the abandoned home over the
past decade a small team of law
enforcement were dispatched to inspect
and investigate the home in person but
they did not return it was at this point
when the incident caught the attention
of the scp foundation who overtook the
investigation and launched a massive
cover story that involved a mass
amnestization of law enforcement
officers and relatives of the missing
persons as well as a planting of a
mimetic agent in the area that induced
brain patterns that would discourage the
town's residents from talking about or
spreading the urban legend of the house
the foundation quickly established
containment procedures and a security
perimeter was set up around the house
after a cursory preliminary batch of
research and testing the house was
decidedly anomalous and was given the
designation of scp-1098-ru
labeled as such due to the investigation
taking place in russia and being handled
by the russian branch of the scp
foundation
scp-1098-ru's containment procedures on
top of the cover story that was put into
place to discourage and suppress the
spread of the urban legend were
effective in deterring civilians from
entering the area originally the city
administration had proposed to destroy
and dismantle the house years ago but
the building's demolition was constantly
postponed by bureaucratic red tape the
entirety of the area was fenced in and
patrolled by an armed security detail at
all hours with the guards shifting
positions every six hours if any
civilians attempted to enter they would
be arrested and interrogated with the
use of amnestics permitted if anything
regarding
scp-1098-ru were to change the guards
would have to report it to site-7 and
wait for further instruction from the
foundation's research it was determined
that
scp-1098-ru was a difficult anomaly to
analyze the house's primary anomalous
effect was a protective one all of the
windows and the front door of
scp-1098-ru were automatically locked
and if someone attempted to enter the
house via physically damaging one of
these spots or anywhere else on the
house they would find themselves unable
to do so instead they would feel
motivated to protect scp-1098-ru
and prevent any damage to it this of
course wouldn't override any other
pre-existing feelings toward the house
so as we saw in rodney's case this can
result in a conflict of interest where
the victim wanted to escape but was
unable to due to the house's protective
trap this effect is only active when a
person is within at least 50 meters of
scp-1098-ru
which explains why the plans for the
house's demolition were plotted but
actually unable to be carried out the
only way to enter scp-1098
is the house's front door through use of
a lock-picking device or another way to
break the door's lock upon entry the
door will close automatically lock
itself from the outside and is unable to
be open for the next hour attempts to
break into the house before this hour is
through are futile as the anomaly's
protective measures will trigger in
order to prevent damage coming from the
house the home's origins are presently
unknown as the foundation is still
investigating them but the urban legend
of the puppet maker who turned his
victims into puppets may hold some
credence
scp-1098-1 is an entity that has been
nicknamed the master of puppets and
you're about to see why but the entity
is a self-containing spirit believed to
be the cause of most of the anomalous
phenomenon within the house the
foundation hasn't found a way to contact
or research the dash one entity beyond
observing the brief appearances of it
during testing so information on the
anomaly is limited to what's been
observed and that would be candles that
are unable to be extinguished or
replaced strange glows of light emerging
from the cracks in sealed windows and
walls hallucinations based on the fears
of the victims trapped inside and the
sound of slow approaching steps from
throughout the house these steps are
unable to be recorded using audio
devices but the foundation has reason to
believe they're produced by the entity
itself still there's a lot of mystery
surrounding scp-1098
where did it come from what is the
scp-1098-1 entity and most importantly
where do the corpses of its victims go
that one is easy to answer the bodies of
those who die inside scp-1098 will be
preserved by the entity and altered to
take on the appearance of puppets their
eyes will be removed and long thick
threads will be sewn into their
extremities but what does scp-1098-ru
need these puppets for a look into the
foundation's initial research documents
regarding the house may provide the
answer the foundation's exploration of
scp-1098-ru
occurred shortly after the object was
put into containment and remains the
primary source of information on how the
anomaly functions and how its
intricacies work the first test involved
a remote-controlled drone equipped with
recording equipment the foundation's
safest way to observe hostile unknown
anomalous territory from a distance the
drone entered and was quickly locked
inside the house as it proceeded it
found several damaged altered corpses of
missing persons in various rooms of the
house the bodies were missing their eyes
and all had thick strings sewn onto them
with stitch marks on the chest and face
areas strangely the bodies weren't
decomposed at all despite some of the
corpses being identified as people who
disappeared months ago the drone survey
also found several objects of interest a
set of surgical knives threads needles
and a prosthetic artificial eye while
the drone didn't detect the dash one
entity foundation researchers could only
speculate as to where and what these
objects were used for and by who the
second test involved sending a d-class
personnel into the building he was
supplied with a flashlight and recording
equipment and was tasked with
re-examining the first floor of the
house the only difference the d-class
observed from the drone exploration was
that the candles were clearly replaced
by newer ones indicating that someone
had changed them footsteps were heard
throughout the home sometimes in areas
that the d-class had just emerged from
upon re-entering one room to investigate
the d-class was ordered to take a
surgical knife back to command for
further study however as soon as he
lifted the knife communication
immediately cut off and the foundation
was unable to re-establish contact a
third test was held shortly after to
determine what happened to the d-class
as well as explore the second floor of
scp-1098
this time using another remote
controlled drone the drone found that
the house on its second floor had a
sewing workshop filled with all the
materials you would expect to find in
such including threads machinery and
tools multiple corpses were found all
dressed in 18th century clothes their
eyes replaced with artificial ones and
with strings sewn into their bodies upon
the drone's return communication was cut
off yet again and when the hour period
was up and the house's door opened there
was no sign of it anywhere the fourth
test into scp-1098 involved another
d-class personnel who was instructed to
attempt to leave the building before an
hour passed after entering the d-class
reported a throbbing headache and
immediate pressure in his ears he
reported that someone was crying in the
farthest room on the first floor but the
equipment couldn't pick anything up
after entering he reported that he saw a
little girl wearing an old-fashioned
dress and she was dancing and crying
being pulled upward into motion by the
strings that were sewn onto her back
these strings on camera were completely
invisible to the foundation leading the
command to believe that the d-class was
experiencing hallucinations the d-class
simply stood and observed almost
transfixed by the girl he remarked that
it seemed like the string stretched on
forever and that there was no ceiling
even though the foundation could clearly
see the ceiling of the room on the
camera after five minutes of silence and
observation a startling clap was heard
as the camera's visuals cut out and then
a male voice but not that of the d-class
spoke
[Music]
when translated from latin to english it
read the performance must be paid for
after this the foundation put a stop to
all further experimentation with
scp-1098-ru
content with the data they had gained
until the foundation gains more
information about scp-1098 and the
mysterious entity inside sending more
resources in will only result in them
meeting a gruesome demise until then
they can only speculate about the true
nature of the entity known as the master
of puppets now go check out
scp-2696 haunted victorian mansion and
scp-4153 haunted house horror it came
from site 9 for more anomalous haunted
houses from scp explained